robert spencer every week on jihad watch
you publish story after story detailing
the slaughter
of non-muslims by muslim jihadis all
over the world this week several more
massacres in africa but no one else
besides you covers the story why
nobody cares barry and nobody cares
because the mainstream media has a
narrative
it fits every story every fact into its
narrative if a story doesn't fit it
doesn't exist
so for example in the mainstream media
view muslims are always in every case
victims
and no matter what they do
they're the victims so for example at
the 20th anniversary of 9 11 there was
story after story after story in the
mainstream media about how muslims
suffered
after 9 11 that there was allegedly
discrimination and harassment against
them that's never justified under any
circumstances but it was wildly
exaggerated muslims are not subject to
widespread discrimination and harassment
in the united states fbi hate crime
statistics bear that out year after year
after year
so
in the case of the persecution of
christians by muslims in africa it
doesn't fit the narrative because the
perpetrators
are the victims for the establishment
media and the victims are
the bad guys christians are never
portrayed positively in the
establishment media so when they're the
victims and the designated victims are
the perpetrators the story doesn't exist
poof it vanishes